he left the room to get a rest yes well
we all kept working yeah and then he
came back he's what two years later with
nothing no injury there's no reason to
leave yeah it was just I'm just gonna
leave because I'm the best the bottom
line you stepped out while we kept
working yeah and then you come back
after we're a little bit wore out and
tired yeah like I thought three fights
you had no reason to leave yeah and so
the way I see it is you left the
competition pool to relieve yourself of
Duty like it was too much for you yeah
the pressure so in layman's term which
move definitely
like I don't respect that as a
championship mindset but I don't like
that dude keep fighting